sommes aujourd'hui dans l'indre à ruffec
le château ici céline et cyril ont
décidé de reprendre une briqueterie
après 13 ans passés dans le cher ils
sont venus s'installer ici et met en
pratique un savoir faire familial de
plus de 100 91 ans objectif pour ce
couple préserver ses activités
historiques ici en berry reportage à
suivre avec calypso vanier maxime
vaillant et marion dubois dans le parc
de la brenne tout au sud de l'indre se
trouve une briqueterie créé en 1774 un
site de 1200 m² où il ya un an un couple
du cher a décidé de s'installer pour
reprendre la production en syrie on est
où exactement
nous sommes à la briqueterie du pic
anciennement les la tuilerie de l'orne
et donc on y fabrique pas des briques
des carreaux des tuiles pour lui dire
quoi on parle de la terre et pour en
faire des briques c'est ça tout à fait
vous montrer on y va céline et cyril
fabrique de a à z briques tuiles ou caro
dans leur atelier une production 100%
berrichonne puisque cyril extrait
lui-même la matière première la terre
d'une carrière dans le cher elle est
ensuite apporté ici avant d'être broyé
affiné malaxer et enfin mélangé à de
l'eau tout le savoir-faire et résines
ensuite dans la maîtrise du dosage de
tous les ingrédients le mélange eau
c'est ça le plus compliqué soit ça sort
ça sort pas ça casse tout soit açores
tout mou et vous avez aucune forme
voilà donc très bien c'est la force d'en
faire c'est qu'est l'eau pour mettre
dans la terre voilà tout simplement
cette recette et ses techniques cyril
les détient depuis des décennies il est
le descendant de plusieurs générations
de riquier c'est génial toujours dans le
respect de la tradition sortie du
moulage la production est stocké dans un
séchoir on les rend dans des séchoirs
dt qu'on appelle c'est à dire c'est un
petit hangar fermé
allaire l'athlète les entrepôts toutes
les pièces à sécher dans
j'irai dans trois quatre jours ce
devrait être sec et se passe au faux
enfournement pour cette dernière étape
l'artisan sera aux petits soins pour le
produit quarantaine d'heures non-stop
son format du bois tout en aidant quoi
on est très très peu a fabriqué sa
maintenant c'est presque disparu bientôt
c'est encore un bout de patrimoine c'est
super quoi cci les produits ont pas la
même la même valeur je dirais pas du
tout le bois ya rien de tel c'est comme
un retour aux bases
il aura fallu près de sept jours pour
passer de la terre au produit fini
aujourd'hui le couple fait tourner à
plein régime l'héritage industriel qui
lui a été légué et qui n'existe presque
plus en france céline et cyril ont à
coeur de faire perdurer ce patrimoine
pendant encore de longues années et je
suis avec céline des moulières la
gérante de la briqueterie du pic ici
alors on l'a vu et on le voit derrière
nous beaucoup de machines plutôt
ancienne c'est important pour vous de
transmettre ce patrimoine
oui ici dans l'indre et ça a été une des
premières raisons déjà dans le cher on
voulait sauver le patrimoine familial
et puis ici il ya un très grand
engouement également pour le patrimoine
donc quand on est arrivé ici
bien sûr il a été 2 dans un premier
temps de sauver le patrimoine de sauver
les machines et du tour m me taire
pourquoi conserver ce patrimoine
pourquoi parce que ça une histoire parce
que quand on pose le bris quand on fait
une brique
elle est là pour des siècles et puis
bah pour l'amour de la terre la passion
du métier et envie que ça continue
c'était important pour vous que ce soit
quelque chose qui ne se perdent pas au
fil du temps ouais surtout pas que ça se
perde c'est pour ça qu'on fait des
visites c'est pour ça qu'on aimerait on
verra bien on veut pas forcer la main
mais si nos enfants on va leur prendre
ça sera avec plaisir
et oui que l'histoire continue parce
qu'on l'a vu dans le reportage mais vous
ça fait des générations et des
générations que vous êtes briquetier
c'est comme ça
c'est dans la famille de mon mari depuis
1828 et puis ici pareil c'est depuis 17
ans et qu'elle donc a eu la famille baud
c'est la prime messieurs lefébure robin
est donc le pareil et une très belle
histoire ici et donc on essaye de
perpétuer la tradition
à qui s'adressent les découvertes que
vous faites ici au sein de la
briqueterie tout au long de l'année
alors les découvertes c'est aussi bien
pour les enfants à partir de 3 ans
jusqu'aux personnes adultes on va dire
jusqu'à 99 ans et après pour les
professionnels qui des fois pousse des
briques sans savoir comment elles sont
fabriquées pour des couvreurs également
pour découvrir la fabrication de tuiles
donc pour toute personne ouverte aux
particuliers comme aux professionnels
très bien merci beaucoup quant à nous
nous nous retrouvons demain pour une
nouvelle visite du patrimoine industriel
en centre val de loire